and what we have now is a bunch of Kim
Kardashian wives that are playing
pretend it's me me me me me my career
what I want and it doesn't matter what
my husband wants and the kids want and
we saw this when Kim Kardashian and
Kanye were married and Kanye repeatedly
told Kim that he didn't want her wearing
certain types of outfits and her
response is that well I was like this
when you married me and while that is a
valid point my question is are we all
going to be exactly the same all through
marriage and is isn't it your job as a
wife to submit to your husband's
Authority even when he changes
directions and again it shows the
problem with the modern wives it's a
lack of control they need to be in
control of everything everything needs
to be the same from the day we get
married till the day we die otherwise I
have been deceit